oh yeah new Star Wars trivia you know
what that means
those of you who do not know these are
my Star Wars curtains when I was a kid
now I wear them as the cape of Star Wars
truth as an adult and some of you may
have seen my Star Wars trailer reaction
and last trailer for Star Wars that came
out people were like you should film
yourself watching it for the first time
it would've been a lot of fun watching
so I was like all right I literally put
my phone up and shitty quality and I
just recorded myself watching this
trailer for the first time mostly
consists of me having a doughy I'd look
like but it's Sara if you want to watch
it but now we're gonna dig in and talk
about this trailer because this trailer
was pretty effing cool and keep in mind
I'm gonna call a lot of people of the
girl or the dude because I don't
actually know their names I am staying
so far out of the loop of this movie I
don't know anything I know the bad guy's
name is kylo Ren that's it so it starts
out it shows the girl she's scavenging
because she's a scavenger I think her in
kylo Ren there's something linking those
two and here's why I think that because
his action figure it's a bummer when
action figures kind of gives something
but his action figure when you press it
it talks and it goes so is it true
you're just a scavenger gets a guy
thanking what's that mean he's her
father
sibling or clone do something vicious
john-boy again I believe that's his TIE
fighter gets shot out of the sky he's
like I've got nothing to fight for
you saw that in the other trailer where
that TIE fighter was just killing
everybody he takes off his helmet looks
like he's gonna cry which immediately
made me feel for his character I was
like this dude like lost his religion he
fought for this evil it's called what
the first order I also know that it's
like Empire 2.0 and now he's like no
screw those guys I don't fight for them
to what do I do it's kind of nomadic in
here so he doesn't really have a place
just I like characters like that because
it makes me really feel for them this
shows kylo Ren he's like no strand of
our word Oh
finish what you started this shows the
Darth Vader helmets all burnt up I saw
this one tweet on Twitter and a couple
people have said this to me and I don't
know if they're talking [ __ ] but they're
like
said I will finish what you started not
finished what he started it's official
Tigers alive no I don't think that's
true I don't think Darth Vader's alive a
because he wouldn't be talking to his
burnt helmet I mean I kind of see it
like a Catholic talking to a crucifix
like thank you for all the wonderful
food you gave me today dude still dead
he's just talking as if you know cuz it
which ultimately you look at kylo Ren
you like do you have you deified Darth
Vader Sith is a religion but this guy
isn't a Sith Lord as I can tell because
name is kylo Ren not Darth this and that
limb is becoming undone we can't have
that happen that would be a catastrophe
this shows kylo Ren like melton that
dudes Brittany's long believed that to
be Oscar Isaac but I'm really terrible
at being able to tell who's who what it
looks like this that's pretty evil [ __ ]
because you know he's like tearing his
head up from the inside out that was one
of like oh god that's dark I really
started feeling the feels when that han
and Leia love theme came on the girls
like there are stories about what
happened to Han Solo's like it's true
the light side the dark side the Jedi
they're real one because the song just
took me back to because the action
looked awesome three because Han Solo
has come around obviously you would
think he would hokey religions and
ancient weapons are no match for a girl
as where's my kid Oh God everything I've
seen in the last few years yeah okay
it's true dude is seeing some stuff
which also was fascinating the whole
concept of Jedi at this point in this
world so it seems they're ultimately
legends it's like people are like were
they real and there are probably
fabrications and stories of what
happened with the assault on the Death
Star at the end of Return of the Jedi
all the rebelling and all that stuff
it's like what's real what's not and so
it was like yeah it's all real I was
there it was as crazy as you think it is
I was frozen in metal and sold to a slug
it's real you could just tell this movie
is filmed with an eye that's just not
George Lucas and I know people who love
the prequels I'm not trying to make you
feel like [ __ ] for loving the prequels
I'm just saying that shot where it's
John boyega and Oscar Isaac and they
passed and John boyega looks back at
Oscar Isaac I was like that's a shot
that would never be in the prequels at
all ever
it is Abraham's 101 and it looks great
it looks great for this universe and
that's see when kylo ren's walking up
towards John boyega Blake has his
lightsaber kylo ren's like arcing up a
blanket like oh god you could tell that
dudes like I guess I need to fight this
guy
I am out match which implies character
development cuz blank is gonna get
better because jump what is gonna become
a cute guys in the end I'm loving this
trailer I'm excited for Star Wars
obviously one of the things I just love
is although you get a couple of
emotional tones in this movie and a
couple of angles that people are coming
from in this trailer you don't really
know anything more about the movie than
you already knew I mean nothing plot
wise was spilled we still don't know it
that big weird Death Star looking thing
on the poster is we don't know anything
else we don't really know the logistics
of the plot it reminds me of the final
trailer for the original Star Trek by JJ
Abrams where you're like oh that looked
great I know nothing about it
I was hoping Abrams would hold to that
and he did he delivered a great trailer
that I'm just excited for the movie for
not only did I grow up on it but it's
Star Wars again I'm telling you this is
the merging of my childhood me and my
adult me coming together to form the
ultimate manchild me which is all I ever
wanted to be so this new trailer guys I
am interested have you seen it what did
you think about it I haven't seen it yet
Wow whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more